hello everyone and welcome to today's
presentation
part of agilent's virtual energy and
chemical summit i am abby powell of
labrutz and i will be your moderator for
today's event
now let's get started before we begin i
would like to remind everyone that this
event is interactive
we encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you
would like during the presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask
the question box and click
send we will answer as many questions as
we have time for at the end of the
presentation
if you have trouble seeing or hearing
the presentation click
on the ask a question box located at the
far
left of your screen i now present
today's speakers
jenny nelson paul kametz
and yon chung atomic spectroscopy
applications in the petroleum industry
for a complete biography
on our speakers please visit the
biography tab at the top of your screen
we will now we will now begin the
presentation
hello everyone and welcome to the
petrochemical summit
thank you for virtually joining us jan
and i are going to give you a tour of
the wooddale center of excellence
in which we're filming right now my name
is paul krampets i'm an application
scientist for
icp and i'll be giving you a tour of the
icp lab
hello everyone my name is yantra i'm
also an
application scientist for icpms
and during journey's presentation paul
and i are going to take you in each
of our labs and show you how awesome our
labs are
are you ready paul i am ready let's take
them on a tour
sure let's go all right
thanks paul thanks yan hi everybody my
name is jenny
and i'll be joining you remotely from my
office in berkeley california
while yon and paul are setting up their
laboratories to take you inside i'm
going to share with you some slides on
the atomic spectroscopy
applications in the petroleum industry
today
we're going to be covering applications
with the mpaes
the icp oas the icpms and the icp
msms so most of you
probably already know all the samples
that arrive in the petroleum elemental
analysis lab
so this could be review for some of you
and if not
maybe you'll learn something so the
first thing we get is crude oil we
normally get a lot of crude oil in the
petroleum element
elemental lab this crude oil can also be
turned into various other
products after crude oil enters the
refinery via the crude distillation unit
or the vacuum distillation unit
it is separated into different
intermediates based on its boiling point
those intermediates can then be taken
through various different
parts of the refinery and final products
are made
final products range between refinery
fuel gas
propane natural gas liquids gasolines
jet fuels petrochemicals kerosenes
diesels you name it there's lots of
things that can be analyzed in the
petroleum lab
other things not on this list but can
also be seen in the elemental lab
are lube oils additives deposits
catalysts raw materials and lots of
other unknowns
so with all these samples and all the
various instruments
and options how do you know what to
choose
well luckily at agilent we have various
instruments that paul and jan will show
you in their laboratories
to help you analyze all those different
samples
we have the mpaes the icp oes
icp ms the single quad and also our
triple quad
icp msms so a lot of those samples
you can analyze on various different
instruments it's just going to depend
on the requirements that you're looking
for to which instrument you choose
let's talk about some applications we've
done
using our microwave plasma atomic
emission spectroscopy
unit or mpa yes a few years ago
we published this paper in energy and
fuels where we were looking at the
elemental analysis of crude oils using
the mpaes
we then published an application note on
this work
after we did the crude oils we decided
to run some even
harder samples and these were the really
heavy fractions so
things that were over a thousand degrees
fahrenheit and higher in boiling point
and we ran those on the mpaes
again we publish that in an agilent
application note
since those two papers we've gone ahead
and we've worked with astm
and we finally have a final method
titled determination of elements
in residual fuels and crude oils by
microwave plasma atomic emission
spectroscopy
this is d8322
we have done another video that is
on this platform that's dedicated the
entire time
just talking about this method so if
you'd like to know more about this new
astm method
be sure to check that out
another thing that we've been working on
with astm is
a method for the biofuels by mpaes
this is work item 56916
and this is a new test method for
determination of metals in biodiesels
in organic mode by mpaes
now we're going to go to paul in the lab
and he's going to show you his
mpa yes
well hello and welcome to the
petrochemical summit here at agilent you
were at the wooddale
center of excellence and right now
you're in the mp
microwave plasma and aa we have a flame
over here on the left
and a graphite furnace over on the left
that's out of your screen but we'll be
focusing today on
the mp we'll give you a tour of the mp
as far as it relates to the
petrochemical industry
and then we'll switch over to icp and
icpms
so thank you again for attending the
virtual summit
and as you can see right now this is the
mp i'm going to go ahead and
switch over to another view for you
so that you can see the a little bit
better view
of the instrument itself right here i'll
give you a view a little bit later
that will show you a close-up of the
plasma
but this is your mp unit this is your
actual torch for your mp
you can you notice that it looks like an
icp torch but it's
but it's a lot smaller it's a lower
temperature plasma
with detection limits that are in
between aaa and itp
um for wear metals and oils however it's
perfect
it has just the right amount of
detection limits um
it can run a wear metal analysis
depending on how
many elements you're doing in a couple
of minutes um
it's linear dynamic range so going low
concentrations of high
concentrations are much greater than naa
i think for those of you that are
familiar with aaa
you're used to diluting 100 or 1000 or
ten thousand times
uh here it's a little bit more similar
to an icp as far as linear range we can
get up into the
hundreds of ppm and then down into the
ppv
range for detection limits um
it's a nitrogen-based plasma rather than
an
argon-based plasma so it is going to be
a little bit cooler
so you do sacrifice some detection
limits on
the higher ip potential elements like
arsenic and flooding but typically
for wear metals and oils you're not
you're not looking for very low levels
of those and it works very very well for
that
so let me see if i can change to one
more view here
and now you can get a close-up of the
instrument itself
[Music]
you can see that the
spray chamber right here nebulizer we're
using a one member
nebulizer this is perfect for oils it's
a high
total dissolved solid nebulizer
um and it handles wear metals uh in oil
um
extremely well your spray chamber is
sitting right here that's to separate
the
small from the large droplets and you
can see the reflection of the plasma
here in the spring chamber it has more
of a red emission from the plasma rather
than a bright white
emission from from argon this is your
so this is your maintenance area here or
what we call the kitchen
and it's very easy to take this apart do
any
maintenance on on the nebulizer the
spray chamber if you'd like
um i'll show you how to take the torch
in and out
quickly as well it's very easy it only
goes in one way and this is your sample
tubing and your drain tubing
so that's a very quick overview of what
the instrument
itself looks like and now i'm going to
switch over here and share my screen
and we're going to show you a little bit
about the software itself and what it
looks like
your the timing of this virtual summit
is actually
um perfect because i just happen to have
a set
of samples from a customer doing
lubricating oils and gear oils that are
in the tray here and that's the data
that you're actually looking at
at the screen you're actually looking at
a phosphorus peak
uh right now on the screen and this is
what we call a worksheet
so if i want to click from foss to
sulfur
to boron um you just click this is a
a check standard that was uh 20 ppm
flats and sulfur
you see that we're getting very very
good recoveries on those checks
the method itself is very simple you
basically choose the elements you want
to run
tell the instrument uh what
configurations you want whether you're
using an
auto sampler or not uh then
you also tell it what conditions you
want to run under
and they're all pretty standard
conditions so it's really easy to set up
thirdly you go into the standards and
you program your standards in
go ahead and put in your samples tell
them where they are in the auto sampler
and then simply go to the analysis
choose the number of samples that you'd
like to run and simply hit
the run button and then it will go
through and run your standardization
your checks and all of your samples
and it's relatively simple to use it's
it's uh the learning curve on this
instrument is is very short
um i think it's it's as easy maybe
even a little bit easier than a flame aa
and it also does
it does these elements sequentially but
it does it all in one method right so
you're not doing one element at a time
you're you're running all those elements
in one methodology
whether you're using lubricating gear or
ear oils or wear metals in the water so
um i hope you enjoyed our quick little
overview
of the mp and now we're going to switch
over
and take you for a tour of the itp lab
thanks paul now while paul switches over
to his inductively coupled plasma
optical emissions spectroscopy unit
or icp oes i'm going to share with you
a couple applications that we've done at
agilent using our icp oes
system by direct dilution you can see
this first one
was where we looked at multi-element
analysis of used
lubricant oils
another example is where we did a high
throughput
multi-elemental analysis of crude oils
this was following astm d5708
another example is the improved accuracy
in the measurement of wear metals in
additives in lubricant oils
and again this was following astm d5185
and one more example for the icp-oes
is the multi-elemental determination of
gasoline
using the icp-oes if you're interested
in
any of those application notes please
reach out to us and we can
share them with you now over to paul in
the lab to look at the icp oes system
hello everyone once again i'm paul
krampitz application scientist here in
the
wooddale coe center of excellence
and you are now on a virtual tour uh on
our second stop i think and this is the
icp lab
so what you're looking at right here and
your timing for the virtual
meeting here is absolutely perfect
because i'm right in the process of
running
a lot of oil samples for an application
study we're doing wear metals and oils
and then all kinds of different engines
engine oils
transmission oils swing gearboxes all
kinds of different things
on engines that are used to
build and disassemble railroads so
kind of a really nice cross-section of
oils that we're running here
this is the 5800 that you see right here
this right here is actually the
spectrometer box
that's in the new 5800 uh back in the
day this used to be
three meters long uh with detection
limits and resolution it's not even
close
to what this new design does for you
it's new optics basically we we're using
some freeform optics and it just gives
you
much better resolution and two to three
times
at least uh better detection limits now
for most wear metal and oil applications
you're not pushing the low ppb levels
uh but the resolution is is a bit of a
big deal
because you have a very structured
background on oils
and what we're also seeing here which is
kind of neat
is um you're seeing the valve
right here and i'm gonna zoom in just a
little bit here
see if i can make this work
okay so this is a little bit better look
of of what we're actually doing here you
can see here's the spray chamber
here's the nebulizer this right here is
the valve
and i took this i uncoiled this loop
right here so that you could see it
a little bit better this right here is a
half mil
loop so we're filling up this loop
with the sample and then we're using
this carrier after the valve switches to
push what's in this loop
up into the spray chamber i'm actually
doing what's called a screening
right now of all these oils that you see
over here
and let me see if i can get fancy here
and zoom in a little bit more so this
auto sampler right here is a c-tac 7400
um autosampler and i don't know if you
can see it yeah i think you can see it
so there's a drip tray
down here and there's also a stir
assembly on the front
so the strip tray you'll see it flip in
when it's moving so you don't flick
little droplets oil all over the place
or cross-contaminate your samples as
it's coming across it
and then you'll also see that when it
comes in next here
like right there this
is stirring the sample ahead of the
sample you're analyzing so by the time
you go to that sample
that sample is already stirred for you
so oil labs really do like this
particular auto sampler
i'm definitely putting it through its
paces right here
i did a quantitative run on
on a tray of samples here i have a lot
more but this is one of the trades that
i ran
and i'm running with a quarter mil loop
and i'm running in about 25 seconds of
sample
i also decided to do something a little
bit different
and i'll show you on the software but
what you're what the instrument is
actually doing right now you can see how
quickly
it's running sample to sample the sample
here
and what i'm doing is something that's
part of what we call intelliquant
and no matter so it's a simultaneous
detector
uh we build a lot of smarts into it so
we can run this intelliq program no
matter what's in your method and it does
pretty much the whole periodic table for
you
plus or minus 20 percent
um i've tightened up the calibration a
little bit because i
updated the calibration to an oil
calibration so
uh the numbers are certainly twenty
percent
um when you compare it to a quant but
here's a really cool thing that some of
you might be very very interested in
if your lab is okay with plus or minus
10 or 15
because you're doing trend analysis this
entire periodic table screening that i'm
doing right now
is taking 17 17 seconds of sample with a
valve
uh and that's where the bigger loop even
i could probably shave a few seconds off
of that
so that that may get some of your
interest
going uh because it's an immense
productivity tool
um as well so let me go back one more
time here
and as you can see this is draining the
system out in the back of the auto
sampler there's a rinse vessel and then
a drain vessel down here so the rinse is
constantly
refilling the rinse vessel in the back
corner here
right back there and then the excess is
being drained into an
organic drain down on the bottom here
that i'm not sure that you can see it's
right down here um but this is this is
basically the setup for
um doing wear metals and oils biodiesels
pretty much any organic application
but again this specifically is is
extremely good
for for oils
now i'm going to scooch over here
and i don't know if you can see where
this probe is but it's almost done
there's 40
there's 40 samples on here
and i started it a couple of minutes
before i started this
um video session here and i've got about
three more samples left
so we ran 40 samples in in a hurry here
especially at 17 seconds sample
so i'm also going to try let's see if i
can do this here
and i'm going to try and share
my screen so let's see if you can see
this hopefully you can see this on your
screen
these are samples these are like i
talked about before these particular
samples are a wide variety of different
samples
and let me let me zoom out here real
quick
and
see if i can talk to you a little bit in
my small box
there we go so i'll just kind of talk to
you while we're going through some of
the software
i apologize some of it's going to be the
back of my
somewhat balding head but we're going to
go through some of the software here
just so you can see so this is an
intelligent screening
method that we're running right now and
like i said we're almost done with all
40 samples
but if you click on a particular sample
like number one i forget what number one
was
uh number one
number one was a burlington northern
santa fe
railroad it was a cummins engine
and the oil brand was a 15 w 40. so that
that's what that particular sample is
that we're seeing here right now
and you can go through here and see that
these numbers
are the quantitative numbers um
as we go through and the interesting
thing is when i compare these numbers to
a full quant
which is 25 seconds sample
the numbers are you know typically
within 10 the way that i have it set up
right now
um and you can you can go through here
and you can see that i have
different types of oils this one happens
to have a lot of magnesium and calcium
in it
where the other ones didn't and you can
see that it's a heat map here
right so red means you have a lot there
orange in the middle and yellow or light
yellow means
they're lower concentrations usually at
a ppm or lower but you can also come in
here and you can
display these different samples as i
click
through them you can display them
and the worksheet's complete so in a
very short order i just ran through and
screened
within about probably 10 percent um all
of those samples
this is amazing to me by the way um
just surely from a productivity tool but
what this also is giving you is it's
showing you surprises in your samples
too
so you you may not have thought that you
had lead in your sample
or you may not have thought that you had
um
uh molly well molly i believe uh but
anyway there could be some surprises in
here that you're not
um that you're not used to seeing
supplier may come back and say hey
you know did you check for um
i don't know scandium or something and
you do have a record of that because you
did a screen of the whole periodic table
you can do it in the bar graph but
what's really cool about this is i can
go to the details
and for the samples i ran whoops
for the samples i ran this program has
all these smarts built into it
meaning it has all the wavelength tables
in in from a variety bowman
mit bowler i forget the other tables
that are in here but
even if you're not a spectroscopist this
box
sort of is so depending upon the sample
you give it
it knows what's in the sample because
it's running everything and since it
knows what's in the sample
it's going to go down here and say well
don't use these
this boron doublet um because
this boron bubble as you can see says it
has a
very strong iron interference on it
which is true
so it's going to tell you hey if you're
running oils use a 208 doublet
instead it's free from interferences it
also knows
how much is in your sample too and
that's what we get from the periodic
table meaning
just from this you know how how much i
have to dilute my sample do i have to do
extra solutions
um i also know what standards do i need
to make for quan i know where everything
is now
as far as concentration so i can make up
i can make up my standards as well
so very quickly and i mean quickly 17
seconds
it does not take much time to to screen
a set like this and you can save
yourself an
awful lot of time because you can catch
flyers you can include elements maybe
that you wanted to quantitate that
weren't in the standard by making it
standard because you know it's there
all kinds of different flexibility tools
to increase your productivity in the lab
for running oils and i'll just click
through a couple more here see if
there's any
any big surprises
i haven't looked at this data yet so you
and i are
looking at this thing at the same time
now this oil is a little bit different
um than the other ones i'm not sure
which one that is
that's 18 18 11 18.
this one just looks a little bit
different to me
and 11 18
is
pardon me 11 18
is also railroad but this is a front
differential from a kershaw machine 4660
machine
so you can tell just by looking at it
that it doesn't look like anything that
i've seen in the wear metals
so anyway it's a fantastic tool
it's a tool to make your method
development a lot easier
and as you can see it's also an
incredibly
good quantitative semi-quantitative tool
for running oils very quickly at the
worst you're 25 seconds of sample
if this kind of accuracy is good enough
then you're down to 17 seconds sample so
that's that's pretty impressive
um so i'm pretty sure that i'm pretty
close
to my allotted time and
with that i'd like to thank you for
coming on a tour i know you've already
done a tour in the mpaa lab
now you've done a tour in the icp lab so
thank you for joining
and then next up we're going to take you
into our
uh lab where dion will take you on a
tour
of it of our icpms units as far
as petroleum is concerned and where
metals are concerned so
thank you thank you once again for your
attention thanks paul
now we are going to be switching gears
and talking about the icpms
so this is one of the instruments that
is in yan's lab
lab and you'll see that very shortly
first i'm going to share with you three
application notes where we used
agilent's icpms systems
running them by direct dilution to
measure different
petroleum samples this first one we
looked at multi-element analysis of
crude oils using icpms
the next one that i'm going to show you
we looked at
gasolines again by direct elemental
analysis
using icpms and then the third one i'm
going to share with you
is one that we looked at metallic
impurities in hydrocarbon fuels
so this is where they looked at things
such as gasoline and diesel
so there's three examples where we'd use
direct dilution
straight into the icpms so running it in
organic mode
so now yan is going to take you into her
lab and show you the icp
single quad instrument
hi welcome to the icpms lab in the
chicago
area one of our center of excellence
now let me give you a mini quick lab
tour
over here we have 8 8900
icpms triple quad instrument
along with a sp s4
auto sampler
with a computer and printer
they all fit on this very nice
lamp bench
and over here we have a 7900
icpms single quad instrument
also with a sps4 auto sampler
computer and printer and they
also fit on this
very nice lab bench
next to it we have a 7 800
icpms single quad instrument
along also with the sps4 auto sampler
computer and printer and also
on the nice left bench
with wheels
hi so i hope you enjoyed the mini lab
tour
now let's get to the main topic of
today's webinar
is to introduce organic samples in
an icpms but before i get to that
first i wanted to show you all the
things that
and the conditions that you will need to
get your instrument ready
for the introduction of organic solvent
now first you will need a oxygen
and argon mixed gas plumbing to your
instrument here i'm showing the gas
inlet of the oxygen and argon mix
that is 20 oxygen and
80 percent argon
this will plump into the back of the
instrument
here i'm showing the optional gas inlet
from the gas outlet to the instrument
now in terms of simple introduction
it's very important to use these viton
tubings
as the peristaltic pump tubing so that's
different
from the aqueous analysis you have been
doing
as you can see these phyton tubings
is compatible with organic solvents
so that the tubing doesn't break down
during the analysis
now in terms of the torch it's
recommended to use a torch
with a smaller injector
diameter inner diameter so this one i'm
showing
is one millimeter inner diameter
injector torch
that's the purpose is to minimize the
organic solvent reaching the plasma
to avoid solvent loading of the plasma
i'm holding up the torch as you can see
the
innermost quartz ii is the injector
and you can see it's a one millimeter
very small
injector that's opposed to the organ
of the aqueous analysis that
typically is used the 2.5 millimeter
torch now
moving on to the cones and lenses
for the organic soften introduction
it's recommended to use a sampling comb
with the platinum tips as well
as the skimmer comb with the platinum
tip
that is the reason is that the platinum
tip
will be able to withstand higher
temperature for the organic plasma
if you use a platinum tip for this
chemical
we recommend to use a brass linspace
so here i'm showing a brass lint space
on top here i'm showing a brand new
excellence that you can purchase from
the agilent store
as you can see the lint space is
stainless steel
so if you are using the platinum tip for
the skimmer comb
with the with the platinum tip then you
will need
to purchase a brass base separately
and then replace that stainless steel
base
for the lint stack
okay now i think i have gotten my
instrument ready
for organic solvent i have the 20
oxygen 80 percent gone mixed gas plumped
into the instruments
i have the torch with a smaller
injector installed sampling comb
skimmer comb both with the platinum tips
and the excellence are half the brass
face and over here for sample
introductions
i still use this double pass spray
chamber
of which i use a separate set of sample
introduction glassware
different from the aqueous analysis
it's just for a quicker and easier
change over
that goes the same with the nebulizer
it's especially for organic but
it's the same type that i have always
been using the micro mist
for the aqueous now the difference
is that i have the phyton tubing for the
sample
tube and i no longer need the t
because internal standard if you're
doing internal standard in your lab
internal standard will be spiking into
the standard
and then i have the waste tubing from
the spray chamber
hooked up now let me take you over
to look at some of the samples i'm
working on today
i wanted to show some of the samples
that i will be running
in the single quad icpms today
so here you can see that i have some
pretty waxy sample
some dark loop oil
type of sample another
oil simple a little lighter
this one is a little thicker i would
guess these are the
oil feed and this one
it's quite a bit lighter and we have
some
gasoline and nafta range
sample over here
we have the really difficult nasty ones
that all the analysts
dislike and if you they can be actually
chipped out to be a really hard
kind of tardy looking sample
[Music]
okay i have my standard prepared
the sample diluted and as here you can
see
i use xylene as my rinse this is the
rinse tray
now i have all the standards ready
and then the sample that is prepped the
one in the back there
is the sample that i was showing you was
very hard as
14 samples and it's all ready to go
for my day of analysis my instrument is
ready
and the sample is prepped another thing
i wanted to show
is that this sps4 auto sampler enclosure
i really like the design of this auto
sampler
has an enclosure as well as a
ventilation port
as you might know that some of the
petroleum samples as well as the
solvents they use for the petroleum
analysis
has a really strong odor so with this
auto sampler enclosure that you can
really
keep the air of the lab clean
hi i hope my mini tutorial for the
introduction
of organic solvents in an itpms is
helpful to you
now i passed the ball back to you jenny
thanks yan
now what we'd like to talk to you about
is some special applications
this application is speciation analysis
so this is where we connect a gc to the
front of an icpms to do speciation
analysis
in these pictures you can see our setup
right here
on the left oh
right here on the left hand side
you can see that we have a gc this is
the 7890
and we have a transfer line going from
inside of the gc oven
all the way over into our icpms and in
this case we used a 7900
over here you can see how that
connection works and where the gc
tran gc um transfer line
comes out of the gc and into the icp ms
here's another picture that shows the
torch this is a special torch that's
used just for this transfer line and
different from a regular torch
that's used in your regular standard
setup
so when we do this type of application
we
are looking uh we you can use it for a
variety of different
applications one that i've worked a lot
on is determine
determining volatile nickel and vanadium
species in crude oil
and crude oil fractions another
application that one of my colleagues
emmett and steve have worked on
is the quantitation and characterization
of sulfur in low sulfur
reformulated gasolines these are just
two examples
of where gc can be used coupled to icpms
to do some more interesting applications
i'm going to talk about the icp msms or
icp triple quad
these are for those extra difficult
applications
one of those applications is the
determination of phosphorus silica and
sulfur
in acid digested lubricating oils using
the triple quad
another example is looking at chlorine
this is an application note
and a paper that we published recently
where we looked at
chlorine in crude oils by direct
dilution
most people know that chlorine suffers a
lot of polyatomic interferences
and so using the triple quad really
helped us to work out the chemistry
and get rid of those polyatomic
interferences
another special application that we did
was we used the triple quad
to look at some asphaltene solutions by
single particle icpms
you can see we published this in energy
and fuels and an
agilent application note
so now i send it back to yon so she can
show you the
icp triple quad in her lab
thank you jenny hello everyone welcome
back to the icpms lab
sitting behind me is the agilent 8900
triple quad icp ms
as jenny mentioned in her presentation
the triple quad icpms is particularly
useful
for those difficult applications
analytes like
phosphorus silicon sulfur
and chlorine however
in terms of organic solvent introduction
into the instrument all the requirements
are very similar to the single quad
icpms that i showed you earlier
now let's take a closer look at the
instrument
okay like i mentioned earlier the
requirement to introduce organic
solvents
in the instrument will be very similar
to the single quad
icpms that i showed you earlier
you will still need 20 oxygen and 80
argon mixed gas plumbed into the
instrument
in terms of sample introduction
you also would need the viton tubing
for the sample tube in the peristaltic
pump
okay with the torch that
is also we will recommend to use a torch
with
a smaller injector the inner diameter
so it's one millimeter inner diameter
injector torch that is to limit
the amount of organic solvents to reach
the plasma
to avoid solvent loading of the plasma
for the combs for sampling comb and
skimmer comb
both we recommend to use platinum tips
combs
that is to withstand the higher
temperature of the organic plasma
in terms of the links we will recommend
to use the brass based
linspace for the
extraction lens
now let's take a look on the inside of
the 8900
icpms triple quad
by looking at the instrument first you
might notice is
a little longer than the single quad
icpms
that is because an extra quadrupole has
been fitted
in front of the collision reaction cell
in a single quad icpms
after the extraction lens there comes
the collision reaction cell after that
will be
the mass selector quadrupole
then is the detector i actually don't
have a spare
quadrupole to show you so a nice
cardboard box
will serve the purpose of demonstration
but for a triple quad instrument
an extra quadrupole
is placed in front of the collision
reaction cell
the extra quadrupole in front of the
collision reaction cell
is used to control the chemistry and the
reactions
inside the reaction cell therefore
more effectively to remove interferences
okay i'm still in the lab as you can see
the 8900 is behind me
but i'm switching over here to
powerpoint slides
because i wanted to show you a little
bit more in detail
how the triple quad icpms removing
interferences with the triple quadrupole
okay however over here in this slide
i'm showing a cropped out of uh
the mass hunter software over here you
can see the control
on the top here and at the bottom here
these are the masks that i
specially set up just for the demo
purposes
as you can see i selected all these
uh difficult elements that we were
talking about
silicon chlorine phosphorus and sulfur
so first let's take a look at
silicon here we are looking at mass
28 but as you can see
that there are polyatomic interferences
nitrogen carbon and oxygen they are all
very
abundant in the pot in the plasma
so they will create a massive
interference
for silicon 28 if you would want to
measure on mass 28
so we are using the hydrogen gas mode
here
and you and doing on mass detection
so essentially what we are doing here is
that we are using
hydrogen to remove away
all the interferences so at mass 28
we are able to see silicon ion very
nicely in low level okay
so let's take a look at here so if here
in the software it tells you we're using
hydrogen mode
we're using the ms ms
triple quad we are doing on math so
we're detecting
28 in the q1 quadruple one
and then also q2 is also 28.
okay moving on to the next mass
next analyte we want to look at is
chlorine
here we we are looking at chlorine mass
35
chlorine is really hard to d to to
attack in low level it's because it's a
very
common contaminant because we're using
hydrochloric acid
and chlorides is everywhere
and it also really hard to detect in low
level that's because its first
ionization potential
is very is relatively high
and on top of that there are also
polyatomic interferences
for at chloride mass 35.
so here we're also using the hydrogen
reaction gas mode we're shifting
the mass 35 to mass 37
then we are shifting the mass here by
reacting that with um hydrogen
it's a sequential reaction with two step
reactions
and essentially we're adding two
hydrogens
onto the chloride 35 to make
mass 37
okay phosphorus so here we are looking
at mass
31 for phosphorus
a lot of polyatomic interferences are
all from elements of very common and in
large amount
in the plasma here we are using oxygen
gas mode we are shifting mass 31
to 47 so we're adding one
oxygen to the phosphorus 31
to make the mass 47 and
all the other interferences will have no
reactions with
oxygen one important thing to
point out here is that titanium also
have a mass
at 47. but with
the q1 we're only allowing mass
35 31 to enter the reaction cell
so titanium 47 would not even enter the
reaction cell
so what comes out of the cell when it
then we set the q2 at 47
we are only selecting the phosphorus
with
one extra oxygen so we can detect
phosphorus in very low level as well
lastly is sulfur 32
very commonly 32 2 oxygen makes up 32
that's a really
large polyatomic interferences for
sulfur if you
like to measure in 32
once again we are using an oxygen
reaction
mode we're shifting sulfur 32
to 48 by adding one oxygen
at mass 16 and then the interference of
oxygen
dimer would not react with oxygen
so that we successfully shift the mass
to a new mass 48 once again
titanium has mass 48
and it's also have really high abundance
as well
but we are setting mass 1 f32
so titanium will not even been
allowed to enter the reaction cell so
what exit the cell
at q2 it's only selecting
mass 48 that are the result ions
from the reaction of sulfur and oxygen
okay i hope you enjoyed my quick
overview of the triple quad icpms
instrument
if you want to find out more information
please feel free to reach out
okay jenny now back to you
thank you yan thank you paul we
are happy to answer any questions
please feel free to ask also
if you don't want to ask any questions
in this format please feel free to email
us
at our email addresses on this screen
thanks again
[Music]
and i just want to say thank you all for
that very
engaging informative presentation
and we uh thank you again for your time
today and your important research
before we go i'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and
again like jenny said questions
submitted during the on-demand period
will be addressed by the speaker
via the contact information provided the
time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand
through in november of 2021
and until next time thank you and have a
wonderful day